welcome back to the five socialism is
not the only thing vermont senator
bernie sanders is demanding
a new book claims the senator has a long
list of hotel demands that include
preferred suites with bathtubs king-size
bed room be kept at 60 degrees
and an extra blanket that has to be dark
blue and made of cotton
we should hook him up with the my pillow
guy sanders also became a huge fan of
private planes
during the campaign at least after
getting over the quote little
embarrassed
pulling into the private terminals thing
uh but greg uh you know you said you
were going to defend him you don't fault
him for wanting to avoid
horrible commercial airports doesn't
that make that's not doesn't make him a
bad person
this is why i like bernie sanders you
know
as you know everybody here in the five
knows that i'm an expert in diva
behavior uh a thermostat
at 60 is not diva behavior it's
necessary when you need to sleep
it's also like you're not supposed to be
cozy when you're working
you're supposed to be cold because it
keeps you awake
and also i mean like look you know he's
got to get somewhere if you can use the
private plane during it it's easier
during a campaign
my problem only is that as a socialist
who's never
actually lived in a socialist paradise
perhaps he should stay in really bad
hotels
because even the worst hotels in america
are better than the ones in cuba
but he should at least get a taste of it
dr sapphire first of all i'd like to
thank you for all your guidance during
the pandemic
your advice your expertise really help
calm the waters
focus us on what it takes bernie sanders
79 years old a year or so older than i
am at what point do we seniors
typically need extra attention
well you know i was researching for this
extremely important
topic that we're talking about because
it is very serious and i have to admit
you know the uh the 60 degrees in a
king-sized bed that sounds quite lovely
to me
but i want to i really want to know what
the blue blanket's all about
why blue he has gray hair you could
definitely see the grays on it
that's the only question but did you
know that kanye west all that he
likes he just wants lip balm shower
shoes and a lot of alcohol
i mean that seems reasonable too yeah i
want space
lots of space dana doesn't everybody
want lots of space don't
doesn't everybody want to fly first
class well
yeah if you ever have a chance to fly on
a private plane it's like wow you do not
ever want to go back but then of course
you're schlepping it to the airport and
going through tsa
and taking your shoes off um the the
line
the blanket thing reminded me of like
linus that's the first thing i thought
of
the other thing i was thinking is that
um
why isn't aoc out there outraged do you
know how many
greenhouse gas emissions are wasted
keeping a room at
60 degrees at all times that is really
outrageous that's the scandal here we
must follow up on it tomorrow
jesse do you remember your first
excellent point my first time what
first class first pass you know it all
it all blends
together but i understand the the blue
blanket that is the power move
because most blankets i see that are
cotton under blankets are white or cream
colored so that you're actually making
the hotel manager go out and acquire a
blue blanket but the rest of it is so
basic what bernie
does it like being near the ice machine
what is bernie gonna ask for a late
check out next time
and then like he requires a bath
bernie's taking a bath in a hotel in
iowa or new hampshire
oh my god the image the the private jet
request was funny though
bernie requests a private jet that's not
too bumpy
yes i mean bernie that's called
turbulence
the the pilot has to just find smoother
air there's not like
a bumpy jet and a non-bumpy jet he's
he's like a child like a shock system in
a car it's kind of cute
it's like cute you know i think he's
adorable
another point for aoc in itself he was
chartering planes
like where's aoc at on the outrage
outrage
the fastest three up next stuck away hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else